ça les copains et toi série est toujours
aussi beau kato maxine toujours puceau
[Musique]
notre premier talent de la soirée c'est
une danseuse de pole dance
je vous demande accueillir celles qui
motif de ouf
ludivine rhétorique franchement c'était
une catastrophe at il reconnu benjamin
castaldi et son numéro de ventriloque
comment tu t'appelles mois dix mois
zinc-titane bien à table et gentille
c'est pas si mal mais c'est pas si mal
ça oui là c'est particulièrement de la
merde mais vraiment un numéro de magie
maintenant maxime gagny et qu'elle iv
novelli et les messieurs je vais vous
faire un petit tour de magie avec deux
boules d'accord bah c'est pas la
première fois qu'il va s'en servir comme
ça comme ça une balle d'accord cette
balle je la mets dans ma mère d'accord
kelly tu vas prendre l'autre balle tu la
fermes pas plus une balle une balle
égalité entre les deux tu souffles sur
la mienne disparition la balle au vote
hama à deux balles sont passibles vous
expliquer comment ça fonctionne
exceptionnellement pour tpm p on voit
que la balle lorsque vous l'a placé à
l'intérieur des secrètement ou toucher
les deux doigts et là elle passe à cette
voie pour complexifier le tour je prends
une troisième balle une deux trois tu
admets train à gauche en étuve à
souffler le plus fort possible souffle
et la regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous semblez de bâle vont commencer les
ovales dans le slip de gens me non non
dans le décolleté non non je déconne la
chute ou non d'accueillir mathieu da
[Musique]
mais sûrement talent ça rappe il est
beau mais c'est pas celui là manille -
au pays de khadr a mené mois voire deux
jolies berbère il me semble que les
merguez serait bien plus belle le soleil
[Applaudissements]
s'est pas fait à temps c'est pas
possible un naufrage
on s'était dit rendez vous dans dix ans
mais comme ça va des copains et toutes
ses rides toujours aussi beau gâteau
maxime toujours puceau
[Applaudissements]
comme angie toujours divorce est
toujours aussi belle non je déconne
[Musique]